now to Hong Kong where a fight broke out
earlier in Parliament's there was fury
from pro-democracy politicians after a
pro Beijing politician was elected as
chairwoman for a key committee it's
meant to scrutinize bills and had been
without a leader since late last year
the backlog of bills includes one that
criminalizes mocking China's national
anthem and 15 anti-government protesters
are appearing in a Hong Kong court
charge over last year's mass rallies the
group was arrested in April accused of
helping organized protests which were
banned by the city's authorities you and
human rights experts have called for all
of them to be released and for charges
to be dropped the first Hong Kong
protester to admit to rioting charges
was sentenced to four years in prison on
Friday
Adrienne brown joins us now live from
Hong Kong so tell us about what's been
happening in court first today with
these 15 pro-democracy campaigners in
jury
well Foley I'm outside West Kowloon
Magistrates Court and this is where the
15 activists have been appearing before
a magistrate during the past hour we're
not sure yet whether nt any pleas and
actually been entered but I think it
seems almost certain that this case
because of its scope will be referred to
a higher court now these 15 activists
aren't just ordinary activists they are
figure heads you know venerated figures
of the pro-democracy movement and they
include people like Martin Lee who's 81
years old who has been part of the
democracy movement now half his life he
helped write Hong Kong's Basic Law the
Hong Kong law also there is Margaret um
another internationally respected lawyer
and of course Jimmy Lai who is a media
mogul here in Hong Kong and his
newspapers have been very critical of
Beijing now I spoke to some of these
activists as they arrived here at the
court they were hemmed in by supporters
and by the media and they all insisted
that they believed that Beijing was
responsible for these charges being
brought they say this is as a result of
increasing interference by Beijing now
there's no doubt actually Folie the
during the past few months we are seeing
a doubling down of Beijing's efforts to
try to contain the protests that of
course began here in Hong Kong last June
but began to sort of Peter out in early
January when kovat 19 took effect here
well you know Hong Kong now appears to
have Kovach 19 under control but what it
doesn't have under control quite clearly
are the protests they have resumed again
there is a resurgent movement but the
protests have been much smaller but
Beijing wants those protests to stop
it's you know it's run out of patience
with Hong Kong and you know just a few
days ago the new head of the central
liaison office here in Hong Kong who's
very close by the way to President Xi
Jingping said that it was time for Hong
Kong to enact a national security law
that would make protests very difficult
to happen that would restrict further
protests and these 15 are standing up to
that and they
now going to I think pay the price
because if they are found guilty they
could face anything up to five years in
jail and the protests haven't been just
on the streets of Hong Kong Adrienne it
was quite the scene earlier inside Hong
Kong's Legislative Assembly yeah it's a
reminder of just how fractious and
broken in a way Hong Kong's Parliament
is I mean rival legislators were
literally physically wrestling each
other to the ground there was a fight on
for the control of Hong Kong's
Parliament and it's all over the
appointment of a chair for a key
committee which has to basically pass
important legislation or present rather
legislation to Hong Kong's Parliament
but there's been a backlog in the last
few months no legislation has been
really been able to be processed and the
pro-establishment camp decided in a
sense to take matters into their own
hands and there was this clash inside
Parliament not a very edifying site 14
legislators from the pro-democracy camp
were ejected a security guard was
injured one legislator was also injured
now why does all this matter because in
Hong Kong in in September there are
going to be elections for the
Legislative Assembly and it's quite
possible that some of those members from
the Democrat Party who were ejected from
Parliament on Monday will now be
disqualified thank you thank you very
much for that Adrienne brown life or is
there in Hong Kong